yeah man that's great once you setup you
don't really have to do anything
super easy maybe off to give it a shot
it sounds like it could be fun are you
guys talking about camping
yeah it's one of the most disgusting
shameful things a person can do how do
you live with yourself no not that kind
of camping we mean actual camping you
know like with a 10 campfire
marshmallows I'm sorry did I not make
myself clear enough camping you either
love it or you hate it in real life it's
the act of hunkering down with a tent in
a quiet secluded area to marvel at
nature's glory but in gaming the act is
rooted in far more devious intentions
instead these digital miscreants lock
down a prime location not to enjoy peace
but rather to incite rage oh my god dude
what are you doing over there camping by
a rock you [__] [__] so how has this
heinous practice persisted for decades
well camping tactics initially started
with early FPS games like quake and the
purpose was pretty simple you'd hide
somewhere typically near a weapon spawn
location that drew a lot of activity and
when anyone entered your line of sight
you'd kill them before they could figure
out where you were but instead of moving
on you'd stay in your hiding place rinse
and repeat like cheese strategies
nothing in game prevented camping in any
way but that didn't stop players from
considering it
dishonorable [__] the frantic nature
of deathmatch assumes the players
typically move around throughout a game
after all
if everyone playing deathmatch camped
there would be no game so clearly
camping is kind of unethical
in those early days of online gaming
private servers were run by all-powerful
admins and players who developed
reputations as annoying campers could
find themselves quickly facing their
wrath but camping became a widespread
enough nuisance that admins had to look
for other solutions to combat the
problem they deployed add-ons like
lithium for quake 2 mods that penalized
immobile players by reducing their frag
counts if they remain stationary camping
was such an issue Enid software's games
that it actually produced one of the
first ever works of machinima a video
entitled diary of a camper starring Ed's
lead designer John Romero as its
deplorable antagonist it's awesome
anyway as first person shooters move
towards more objective based gameplay
camping diversified to players would
still loiter in advantageous locations
don't know where do you think you've
gone me you don't get bored and pass on
you but they'd also hole up inside their
own spawn points or crank up the BM by
camping their opponents this is actually
good because they're not gonna think to
look for the Demoman just sitting there
waiting for them to spawn eventually
camping made its way from FPS is to
MMORPGs where it evolved yet again in
groundbreaking titles like EverQuest
killing monsters or mobs was the primary
way you gained experience or specific
item drops so players would commonly set
up camp in certain areas some of these
camping spots even developed ridiculous
nicknames yeah assassin supply room also
known as a so and if a SUP wasn't your
camping ground of choice there was also
the finger looking good KFC penthouse
and hermit yeah you just murdered this
guy who wants to be left alone every 10
minutes for experience
gruesome and grisly video games in World
of Warcraft gameplay was tailored more
around completing quests rather than
grinding mobs although it was
occasionally still necessary in vanilla
camping and Wow served two main purposes
grinding for rare spawns and more
notoriously griefing on PvP servers
someone would stand over your body after
you died and kill you again as soon as
you respawn these incredibly annoying
encounters were able to bring the worst
out of WoW players a group not known for
mincing their words that's why you
[__] [__] don't [__] with people
in real life you have to [__] the people
on the internet because will [__]
take you out to the [__] balls and in
WoW
camping wasn't always a fair fight
high-level players would often travel to
leveling zones to gank and camp
so-called lo V's Blizzard even
acknowledge their community's
frustration with the tactic by making it
so that when you type slash camp it set
up a cute little campfire just kidding
it kicks you from the [__] game
inevitably camping made the jump to
MOBAs as well in dota 2 it manifests in
fountain camping a popular form of
infuriating BM
[Applause]
while in league of legends it's more
commonly used to describe a jungler who
focuses on ganking one lane constantly
to get their teammates ahead
although the practices maligned by its
victims it's largely an accepted aspect
of the game you want the opportunity to
do a little bit more damage I'd like the
opportunity to play League of Legends
don't hate the player hate the game son
so what exactly can you do about camping
well in modern FPS games the tactic is
actually more often a liability once
opponents understand the map there's
almost always a way to get behind the
camper and deliver a vengeful killing
blow although deathmatch style games
waned in popularity for a while they're
back in full swing with the Battle
Royale genre and the developers of these
games quickly realize that on such
expansive Maps camping could be an issue
to nullify its threat they decided to
make the playable area shrink in varying
ways over time forcing the sneaky
cowards to adapt their strategy
developers have also tried to prevent it
in other genres by introducing mechanics
the reveal campers positions whether
it's in the form of abilities that allow
players to see through walls to see
indirect fire weapons and maps that make
using them easier and even Intel tools
like drones and Rainbow six siege
additionally the widespread
incorporation of Kel cams and spotting
mechanics have made it so camping
players are quickly transformed from
being the hunters into the hunted so the
bottom line is that against an
experienced player with all the tools at
their disposal camping today just
shouldn't be an effective strategy sure
you might get caught off guard once or
twice but anything more than that and
you might need to take a long hard look
in the mirror I don't know man but I'm
starving I went to get some oatmeal this
morning but it was all gone camping the
spawn after all if everyone playing
deathmatch camped there would be no game
so clearly deathmatch is not deathmatch
deathmatch is clearly an ethical well it
kind of
that's right so how has this game Amos I
almost said how is this heinous act yeah
yeah
yeah forget the trailer just give me the
mirror yeah this is camping right